محطه القطار الرئيسيه
وقد عادت الى العمل بعد اغلاق دام نحو
سبعه شهور عقب مقتل اكثر من 50 شخصا امام
بوابتها
وهذه هي الساحه الرئيسيه في سلوفيا صفارات
الانذار لم تعد تعني الكثير لسكان هذه
المدينه التي ظلت شبه خاويتين لاشهر عده
عندما كانت القوات الروسيه على بعد نحو
عشره كيلو مترات منها
هكذا تحاول مدن شرقي اوكرانيا العوده الى
الحياه
[موسيقى]
لكن هذا المشهد قد ينقلب في لحظات راسا
على عقب وهذا ما دفع اكثر من 70% من سكان
هذه المدن
لمغادرتها يقول من بقوا هنا لا حصانه لاي
مكان
لم اعد املك شقه لكنني بقيت مع عائلتي على
قيد الحياه نزعت في بدايه الحرب وعدت
عندما ظننت ان الوضع اصبح افضل كنت مخطئا
واليوم اغادر ثانيه ولا اعرف متى يمكنني
العوده الى هنا لذلك اخذ ما بقي من امتعتي
هذا مستشفى كراماتورس للامراض العقليه
يقول القائمون عليه ان قصته تشبه حاله مدن
مقاطعه دونيسك في المستشفى الذي كان يتسع
لنحو ثلاثمائه مريض قصف في بدايه الحرب ثم
عاد للعمل مع وجود نحو 20 مريضا فقط لكنه
عاد للتوقف بعد ان قصف مره اخرى
هنا كان ينام المرضى هذا المكان كان يتسع
لاربعين مريضا وبينما كنا ننتظر عوده بقيه
المرضى هذا ما حدث الدمار في كل مكان وهذا
طبعا بعد ان نظفنا اثار الانفجار
انتقلنا الى بلداتي وقرى شماليه مقاطعه
دونسك المشهد مختلف هنا يبدو وكان زلزالا
ضرب المنطقه فهذه القرى ظلت لاشهر عده
ساحه حرب ضاريه انسحبت منها القوات
الروسيه في سبتمبر ايلول من العام الماضي
وعلى الرغم من ذلك من الصعب ان تجد فيها
اثرا للحياه يقول كثير من سكان مدن وقرى
اقليم دومباس ان عودتهم الى بيوتهم تبقى
غير امنه وربما تبدو مستحيله طالما ان
الهدوء الذي تعيشه هذه المدن نسبي وطالما
ان الحرب لم تضع اوزارها بعد امر لا في
الجزيره من قرى شمالي مقاطعه دونيت